a 1% will try to convince you that I
don't like freedom I like freedom as
long as it's not for people who are too
rich or are to pull I want freedom for
every one of the people in the middle
government bad
[Music]
democratic socialism is about is having
a government which reflects the interest
of ordinary people rather than is
currently the case of the billionaire
class so the term fascism is thrown
around so much nowadays it's a fun word
what's a fun word and you've heard it a
lot in your college gender studies I'm
sure oh absolutely but it's lost all
meaning people don't really know what it
means and so I want to make the case I'm
looking at their policies and what they
want to do and their worldview Bernie
Sanders is the most fascist of all the
candidates how that kind of incendiary
language he's just a fascist for
mediocrity
he's a mediocre fascist no I know allow
me to present my case and I know I know
if I'm people complaining Bernie Sanders
shows will like this well good white I
understand but for all intents and
purposes our Bernie Sanders sounds like
he's portrayed by Gilbert Godfrey it's
funnier that way so first let's look at
the definition of fascism it's important
by the way I found what I was looking
this up don't go by the first google
thing merriam-webster Google shows up
right away an authoritarian and
nationalistic right-wing system of
government and social organization
right-wing second fascism is not
right-wing I'm installing more Stalin
Mao Pol Pot Hitler Che Guevara
these were not these were National
Socialist Party of Germany these are
people who implemented 80 percent taxes
disarmed a popular certainly not what
people would consider right winter that
in America may be old World War two
European politics I don't know I don't
know but not what you know what Google
is doing yeah absolutely
how do I know what Google was doing
because if you search the definition of
communism or socialism something on
which people unilaterally agree would be
left-wing it has no mention of left
talking at all none so fascism
right-wing socialism communism which are
actual left-wing political systems of
government we're just going to omit that
so let's look at the merriam-webster
definition of fascism okay it has a
political philosophy movement or
jeem that axalta nation erase above the
individual and stands for centralized
autocratic government headed by datoria
leader severe economic social
regimentation and forcible suppression
of opposition that's Bernie Sanders ok
centralized government regimentation
suppression of opposition so what do I
mean by this let's look at a few let's
start with a few things so Bernie
Sanders right he comes out and he says
private insurance people well hold on a
second the people will not have to pay
for it the people so he said the people
right he's talking about the people
signifying this group of people who
matter who will be affected where's
where's the money coming from it's not
coming out of thin air someone's paying
for it you look at his tax plan he wants
to tax wealthier Americans more
specifically any household joint over
250,000 household income you're you're
going to be paying if you live in a
moderately liberal state over 60% in
taxes not to mention everything else so
those don't count as the people because
he's saying the people won't have to pay
what is he saying about the group of
individuals not they're basically
subhuman they're not to be included in
the people the wealthy the successful
are not the people only these folks
count as the people that's a very
limited definition of people anyone
above it doesn't that's fascism so let's
go here while appearing in New Hampshire
in September okay Sanders said that he
had talked to a guy from Denmark but
also hard to be very rich sons to me
that's fascism for mediocrity right
we're talking about social regimentation
political and forcible suppression of
opposition so
it should be very very hard to be very
rich very very poor all of you have to
be in the middle otherwise you're not
part of the people right the people
won't pay for it so if you're rich no
you're not part of the people if you're
poor no you're not part of the people it
should be hard to be very rich and it
should be hard to be very poor so how do
you enforce that by taxing the wealthy
and incredible amount and giving to
people who are poor so if the poor
people maybe some of them deserve to be
poor it's not popular to say maybe poor
people deserve to be poor right maybe
they're lazy maybe they don't work maybe
they don't employ people maybe we don't
start businesses no no no we need to
make them part of the people by taking
from the non people the wealthy and
making sure that everyone is in the
middle from his own words it should be
very hard to be very rich or very poor
another example a good example right
Bernie Sanders believes I don't agree
that sounds mean
no I don't agree I believe that you have
the right to be paid an appropriate
amount correlating exactly to the value
added by your position or services
that's what I believe but I'm not a
fascist see I don't let some sake fast
food for example okay so everyone has a
restaurant right that you go like a fast
food but I don't know if it's McDonald's
for 20s you everyone here right was it
the KFC that's pretty bad Oh arable
you're like just I just don't go to that
one on 28th Street because they never
get the order right they're constantly
screwing up so you you actually you'll
reroute your house drive away I don't
know hey right exactly right so we have
to get when it gets there right half the
time right that's time just half you
just want a portion of your order to be
right so what is that fast-food worker
doing to that business now that
fast-food workers the people the
business owner if he's successful above
the tax brett is not the people he's
costing that business owner money
because you have said I'm going to go
down the street right but the business
owner can't reflect that in the payment
because he's not
people he has to pay him a minimum $15
an hour so what inevitably happens the
business goes under because it's all
about the interest of that person not
the value they add not how good of a job
they do it doesn't matter that you no
longer want to go to that KFC because
you get a a rat anus instead of a white
meat chicken breast whatever it is that
you order it doesn't matter you barely
have to show up but that's fascism for
mediocrity who does that affect people
just think that only helps that helps
people make a living wage no but
actually disregarding the business owner
right we have established that people
are successful to invest who employ
they're not the people they're not to be
included but it also affects employees a
$15 minimum wage now who do you think
the $15
I believe I because fascist right I
don't believe that people should be paid
their service either the people should
be paid this set I'm up it should be
hard to be rich and it should be hard to
be poor you make this much okay who does
that affect negatively as far as
employees the crappy you think it's the
crappy employee who causes you to go
down the road or do you think the really
good employee who do you think gets
negatively affected I want to go with a
good employee what's a good employee
because guess what happens when you pay
someone $7 an hour or $8 an hour but
there's an employee on the contrary
right who has a report card where he's
getting every order right he's smiling
people I have it there was a Dunkin
Donuts there was a lady who was so nice
we became friends she had no teeth but
she was really really sweet she was just
always chipper and make sure to go above
and beyond
you remember those people and those
people tend to move up pretty quickly
and not to $15 an hour positions so what
happens the crappy person who can't put
a cheese slice and a fillet of fish gets
$15 an hour no matter what the good
employee who deserves $25 an hour what
do you think they probably get paid
I'm gonna go fifty $15 an hour the
crappy employee gets paid the exact same
amount as the good employee your problem
is going to the drive-through in the
first place
your carbon footprint you should be
riding a bicycle so the business owner
who they want to pay good employees more
they want to do that trust me I'm a
business owner they want to pay good
employees more you don't want to pay any
more I don't want to pick my I want to
pay good employees more so they want to
pay their good employees we're not ones
who wake up at 10 o'clock and say their
iPad didn't wake them up not ones you
forget to replace the breakers so the
studio lights go out they want to pay
their employees more because it reflects
well on their business but since he
since he can't because he has to pay
everyone $15 an hour you're all everyone
is the same we here's the thing Bernie
Sanders wants to legislatively enforce
that everybody is treated this is paid
the same regardless of performance and
it's a huge irony we want big money out
of politics we want big money out of
influence you want more mediocre
influence you want the people who are
not contributing the people maybe 47% of
them don't pay federal income tax those
are the only people because it's easy
for you to buy their votes by
legislating mediocrity we have to ensure
there's no successful money in politics
and I'm not for crony capitalism I
understand it so what do we want to
inject the influence of the crappy
employee who wants to vote in $15 an
hour so he can screw the employee who
deserves $25 an hour so the business
owner is screwed it doesn't matter if
has been as a successful or not he's not
allowed to pay based on performance and
the good employees are screwed so that
it's really hard to be rich and really
hard to be poor everyone has to be right
in the middle otherwise you're not part
of the people that's mediocre fascism
and that's plenty centers
right to this channel so Steven can play
not gay Jared a living wage